another day another angelina jolie brad
pitt legal battle
that's life isn't it a company once
owned by the actress filed a 250 million
dollar lawsuit against her ex
but we're hearing this might come down
to strategy
a source tells e.t this latest legal
move is yet another rehash and
repackaging of old material to try and
distract from the other party's behavior
so what's being alleged
well remember the multi-million dollar
vineyard where they got married in 2014
years earlier brad and angelina bought
chateau miraval winery estimated to be
worth 162 million dollars
fast forward to 2022 the vineyard is at
the center of their court drama you look
at your options and you make the best
decision it's alleged brad pitt
masterminded a years-long plan to seize
control of the chateau
secretly moving assets to benefit
himself and his allies at the company
which in turn devalued angelina's then
company's stake and these docs say it
was retaliation for brad and angelina's
divorce and custody battles with their
six children
calling brad's alleged acts unlawful and
oppressive conduct
this is a really high stakes case not
only is it personal between angelina and
brad there is a lot of money at stake
here but how did this legal battle all
begin
it started in february when brad first
sued angelina over the sale of her steak
in the winery to russian oligarch yuri
scheffler claiming the move was meant to
damage his involvement with the company
fast forward to june and brad's attorney
doubled down claiming angelina
intentionally sought to cause her ex
harm
alleging she knew sheffler and his
associates would try to control the
business brad built ultimately
undermining his involvement brad is
saying i wanted to continue to run this
business and continue to grow it so down
the line if i wanted to sell it it could
have been worth even more
the lawsuit claimed that per the terms
of their finalized divorce the couple
had a mutual understanding that neither
of them could sell off their interest in
the chateau without the other's consent
and according to his legal team it was
brad's passion that turned the company
into a multi-million dollar business
angelina and brad are no stranger to the
court system and have this on the list
of the many cases that they have to deal
with including the custody battle
brad was seeking monetary damages legal
fees and wanted angelina sailed to
sheffler to be voided
the docks also claimed angelina never
returned to the chateau after the two
filed for divorce in 2016.
[Music]
you